to check here would you like to
save this nope and i'll see if it's
going
live on my channel and then
if it does there we are
very good all right we got over 13
people watching
so i am going to welcome professor adam
frank of the
university of rochester new yorker are
you a native new yorker too adam like me
uh
jersey just across the river oh okay
jersey it's the best you know
small price to pay to pay to get out of
uh new jersey
20 bucks or so that it costs a bridge
no i love it i love it uh and it's such
a pleasure joining us from rochester the
the house that uh kodak built if i'm not
mistaken and we're gonna talk today
about searching for techno signatures
this is alien month
not only on the into the impossible
channel we've had on mick west seth
shawstack
and later tonight we will have michael
shermer and eric weinstein
debating ufos um but we've also uh
we've also had on in the popular culture
from 60 minutes
to uh to pay to an op-ed you wrote in
the new york times
which is called uh ufos in the search
for alien life
from june 6. this is an actual uh the
truth may be
out there but i'm a physicist who
searches for ufo
for ufos they don't impress me or aliens
and
ufos don't impress me anyway adam how
are you doing today in my
former home country my landsman of new
york
uh that's great so i am going to just
broadcast to the universe that we
are live and i want people to join us in
the live chat for our members
i am brian keating the um
the also the co-director of the arthur c
clarke center for human imagination here
at uc san diego
and arthur c clark as you know adam was
no was no stranger to the concepts of
interstellar and inter-galactic perhaps
uh otherworldly intelligences natural
and otherwise so it's befitting that you
are joining us in in this month
for a live webinar what i'm calling the
journal club where we go over
interesting uh topics by world-renowned
scientists first of all adam i want to
thank you so much for all the outreach
you do
can you say a word or two about uh what
motivates you to do the prolific amount
of writing
of teaching and outreach that you do you
don't get paid for it as far as i know
you make a little from a book but
yeah you don't get paid for it so why do
you do what you do so well
uh you know um the love of science right
i mean so what uh you know
one of my i started i fell in love with
science when i was five years old
because i found my one of my dad's
science fiction
uh pulp magazines um and then
uh you know that that passion never
cooled and then i discovered carl sagan
when i was you know a teenager and his
writing was so clear
um and and you just enlivened my own
sense of science's beauty and then
yeah i sort of felt like there was a
responsibility to uh give back
to to tell people about this part of it
is just you know when you think
something is really cool whether it's
the avengers or
you know or you know 2001 whatever your
favorite pop culture
you want to tell people about it and
science is so awesome i want to tell
people about it but i also believe
you know i still have that enlightenment
ideal that that that
science is is one way i mean you know i
think there's parts of the enlightenment
we need to move
but but the uh the sciences is a way for
having a just society it's a way
it's a way to have public knowledge um
so i'm kind of an evangelist of science
both because
you know it shows you how remarkable the
universe is but it also
can be a route to having a just an
equitable society
so yeah and also i think the notion of
science fiction
which often times as you point out in
this wonderful book
light of the stars uh which we won't
talk about as much in this conversation
is more of a
actual as they say journal club seminar
colloquia whatever you want to call it i
want to show for my viewers
out there what it's like to be an actual
scientist and so i'm never going to dumb
it down i always say
this is actual legitimate realistic
cutting edge science adam is one of the
most
renowned scientists of our time he's
also a communicator's written many books
i have this one in physical form and it
will go
to one of you lucky uh listeners out
there who registered you can still
register
there's a link in the youtube text
description box you can win this very
copy
it's endorsed by the some of the most
renowned people around the world from
sean carroll martin lord martin reese
kim stanley robinson and jill tarter
who's a friend and past guest on the
show we're going to talk today
about searching for techno signatures
and this is um
you know what we all love to do when we
go to the club and we listen to
the signatures of techno music no we
want to
uh turn it over to professor frank and
those of you out there i also want to
give this as an opportunity for young
people
uh to look at how a faculty member like
adam teaches consider applying to
university of rochester
graduate school undergraduate um you
know this is one of the
top renowned universities in the world
and
the type of research that you can do in
astronomy i think is the broadest
would you agree adam of any type of
field you can do everything from biology
to plasmas and everything in between
right that's what makes astronomy
astrophysics so interesting it's it's
your you got to be a generalist
um and so yes i love it so i'm going to
turn it over to adam
uh and he will run the show in terms of
uh
giving the actual tech talk and then
we'll take questions you can
put your questions in the chat box and
i'll monitor those and again don't
remember or don't forget
uh to uh to take a look at
the contest enter if you want to win a
copy of this awesome book
written by uh written by professor frank
while uh he and i were both writing for
the same publisher
norton this i think came out around the
same time in 2018
and i'd love that book when it came out
and i'm hoping to hear
another book coming from professor frank
soon so adam take it away my friend
uh thanks first of all thank you for
having me on you know also i'm a big fan
you know as they say you know your work
as well and all the outreach you do as
well as it's the real science you know
the actual
day-to-day science that you do so uh so
we're on the same page when it comes to
the
doings you're trying to balance doing
actual science and doing actual science
outreach
so all right so um this will hopefully
this won't take more
more than like 40 minutes or so but it's
a little talk a little talk about aliens
um so i want to talk about techno
signatures bio signatures and try and
wrap in also
why this matters to us on the earth um
so okay so uh here's where we're going a
little
background or at least you know road map
first we're going to talk a little bit
about the history of seti because it's
fascinating
then we're going to talk about these
three revolutions that have occurred in
astrobiology that really change how we
think about life outside
of other places other than the earth uh
then we're going to talk about
biosignatures because you can't talk
about techno signatures unless you talk
about biosignatures
and then we're going to talk about sort
of this new this is very new really the
resurgence
in the study of of intelligent life in
the universe
um and we'll talk a little bit about how
you know what with the systematics that
are coming out of it
and then finally if we have time we'll
touch on on how this relates to what's
happening on earth now particularly
you know this amazing thing that's
happening with us with climate change
and the anthropocene
okay so let's start where it all begins
and it all begins with enrico fermi in
1950
as he and three friends are walking to
lunch basically
um at los alamos and uh they're talking
you know
as they're walking they're talking about
a funny cartoon in the new yorker which
i show here
which was blaming the disappearance of
trash cans on ufos ufos were already a
thing they were a new thing but they
were a thing
i mean that got them as physicists will
start talking about you know
interstellar travel
traveling at you know light speed what
was possible etc um and then the
discussion moved on to something else
and then about you know 40 minutes later
after they've sat down and they're
eating their burgers or whatever they're
eating
suddenly in a very fermi kind of way
fermi blurts out
but where are they right and apparently
everybody at the table just cracks up
because they know enrico fermi this is
the way
fermi works um where he will like you
know in an instant see the heart
of a problem and the heart of the
problem he had recognized was that
if intelligence if technological
intelligence is
common then it would probably spread
from one
star system to another and why aren't
they here now why weren't they already
here
um uh so that sort of this was and as
we'll see this was the beginning of
trying to scientifically formulate even
though he wasn't scientifically
formulating what came out of this is
going to be the first scientific forum
one of the first formulations of the
problem of thinking about civilizations
elsewhere
the next big step in seti was project
osma
which was taken by you know the great
hero of this field frank drake who was a
new hire
at the greenback national radio
observatory and managed to convince
his colleagues that like hey we got this
great big telescope why don't we look
for signals from other civilizations and
it's a great
very funny story which i talk about in
the book uh in light of the stars
um and you know so they met they built
the detectors
uh they did the search they searched for
i think for it was four nearby stars
they didn't detect anything but it drew
a huge amount of attention
got national-wide attention people were
flying in to see it
and this was really the beginning of the
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
the formal
scientific search even though people
have been talking about this since
aristotle
um this was the beginning of a true
formal search
so after uh project osma is over
frank drake is kind of looking over his
shoulder to find out like who's laughing
at him
um but instead what happens is he gets a
call from the national academy of
sciences because they want him to run a
meeting
on of all things interstellar
communications so he puts together this
team of all-stars um of people you know
that he invites and that there's seven
of them and they spend a few days
talking
about this problem and in order to uh
basically what he
what drake was doing was pulling
together a agenda for the meeting
and he writes down this equation which
would go down
in infamy maybe not infamy but it would
go down in history
um and really what this was this was
just his attempt to break the problem
break the meeting up
into bite-sized chunks and this is the
drake equation and let's just very
quickly go over it
because you'll see what he did he was
trying to break the problem of
n how many pro how many civilizations
aren't there
out there that we could communicate with
into bite-sized pieces
this is the very essence of science you
know you have a hard problem
break it up into parts that you can
solve and so the first part
is uh or the for in this equation the
total number of civilizations is going
to equal
the number of stars forming per year
times the fraction of those stars that
have planets
times the number of planets that are in
so-called habitable zone the place where
life could form
times the fraction of those planets that
act where life actually begins
times the fraction of that life that
goes on to form that
to evolve intelligence times the
fraction of those intelligences that
divide
that develop technological civilizations
times what i like to call the
final factor which is the lifetime of
those civilizations
so you know this equation became sort of
the
standard way of breaking the problem up
and some people like to deride it and
say oh it's not worth anything
but i think they're wrong this is
there's a reason why this equation has
lasted because it allowed us to see what
we needed to know
um in order to know the answer to the
problem
and now people have spent their entire
lives working on just one of those terms
in the equation
um okay so that was that was the drake
equation very important another thing
that happens in the early 60s is freeman
dyson a physicist writes a paper
where he suggests that you know one
thing a civil and advanced civilization
might do is
um surround its star with some kind of
device that you know could absorb solar
energy
thereby uh harnessing the entire energy
output of a star
and this became a what was known as a
dyson sphere
and it also became sort of a standard
in the discussion of um of
extraterrestrials so dyson spheres
like the drake equation enters into this
literature
of seti also along those same lines
comes the kardashev scale
based on uh some a work that a russian
uh physicist kardashev did where uh and
again this is energy right so you know
if you're a physicist you want to think
in terms of the things you're used to
and and it's you know energy momentum
etc
are going to be the quantities you think
are going to be important that any
civilization is going to have to deal
with
so kardashev developed a scale where
that would
talk about the amount of energy a
civilization had at its disposal
which also was about detection too
because if they were harnessing that
energy
some of that energy would spill over or
you might see the effects of that energy
being used
so a type 1 civilization was a
civilization that could use
all the power available to the home
planet type 2 was all the power
available to a star
or from the star and of course that's
like the dyson sphere right you wrap
your star
with solar panels and collect all the
energy and a type 3 was like the entire
galaxy
you know 400 billion stars worth of
energy you had at your disposal
so this also the kardashev scale becomes
a sort of standard in the discussion
of seti um and now uh a few years
earlier once we get to the early 70s we
see that fermi
question fermi's question become
formally the fermi paradox in a paper by
heart
in 1975 where what he did is he
recognized that even if you were
traveling
sublight speed that um the time it would
take for you
for a civilization hopping from one uh a
star system to another you know laying
down let you know
leaving a settlement to become a civil
its own civilization that the time scale
would take for this
settlement wave to expand across the
galaxy
was much shorter than the actual age of
the galaxy
so a tiny fraction is a matter it only
takes about 600 000 years for
moving at a tenth of the speed of light
for this this propagation wave to get
across
so you know for him for heart this man
he called this
so so what hart did with this
with this uh con this this fact was he
he paired that fact how fast it would
take to get across
the galaxy with the fact that there's no
aliens here now we don't see any
remnants of an alien civilization we
don't see any aliens now
barring ufos um so his fact
a there's no aliens here now must mean
that there's no aliens at all so for
for for uh heart the the
the fact that there were no aliens here
now had to mean there were no aliens
anywhere we were the only intelligence
in the universe now some people tried to
rebut this including sagan and others to
say
look this expansion wave it's gonna
stall
maybe there's you're gonna open up holes
because of supernova
um so people tried to rebut this and
we're gonna see later on this is now a
new you know people are starting to
study this again including my own group
uh my own collaborators so um that's
really when
fermi's question becomes a formal
scientific problem of fermi's paradox
now there's another version of the fermi
paradox i want to talk about as well
heart's version was direct you know it
was sort of like why isn't anybody here
now that i can see
but uh you know radio said he had been
uh ongoing for a while and there was
uh some people like um uh david brinn
wrote a great paper on this
saying like well we haven't found
anything yet in the steady searches
we've done
and he turned this the great silence and
the greatest maybe
watching actually he just emailed me uh
to get the link to the video so
hopefully david is watching right now
so um that was an excellent paper and so
david so you know that was the idea that
like well we haven't heard anything so
you know where is everybody are we alone
and along with this came another
important idea the great filter well if
we don't see anything
perhaps there's a filter somewhere in
evolution
that keeps advanced civilizations from
forming maybe it's early on maybe it's
very hard to form life
maybe it's just very hard to get
intelligence maybe it's after where we
are where like you know
every intelligent civilizational
civilization blows itself up
so this great filter idea also enters
into the literature
all right then by the time you get to
the 70s and such you're now getting the
second generation of seti pioneers
um and you know seti had started started
to get some steam it was still
not mainstream astronomy but it started
to get steam and so there were um the
second generation people like jill
tarter
woody sullivan who was uh a
astrophysicist at the university of
rochester is
um and was my you know he was the first
guy i ever really talked to about
seti what he's great i love him um uh as
seth's showstack and others and so you
know now seti is continuing
uh to build up steam and it's actually
seti it's gonna be seti researchers who
are gonna push
the uh the development of cameras or
techniques to find exoplanets
this was apps they were absolutely
instrumental uh in that uh
push um now the important thing though
to understand is that this time
people were written seti clap what i'll
call classical seti
was really very much focused on ready
radio beacons right the idea that
somebody was
you know sending out signals that were
meant to be found
um so the emphasis on radio was because
radio was more sent you could
the detectors would be more uh sensitive
over large distances
longer wavelengths also meant that the
radio waves could propagate through dust
and such um and the beacon part was
because
you know the seti's a very challenging
problem uh you don't know where to look
you don't know when to look you don't
know what frequency you're supposed to
be turning you're tuning your
uh your your radio telescope too and you
don't know exactly what to look for
so that's why beacons were you know
beacons made sense given the constraints
that you had at the time and of course
this is what exactly you know in the
famous movie
um contact which you know the younger
generation may not know but you should
watch
because it's still super cool um uh so
beacon city was sort of the emphasis uh
for this
this uh up until the second generation
but then comes the death of seti the
death by the what we call the giggle
factor
um and uh what happened is the first
time this happened in 1978 senator
william proxmeier
nasa was about to fund a big seti
project
um but proxmyer awards that project what
he called the golden fleece award the
fleecing of taxpayers
and literally nasa was not allowed to
fund seti from that
uh so that happens and these people you
know okay it calms down for a while in
the 1990s again nasa tries to fund
some seti programs and there's another
big uproar you know these are
politicians trying to score points
oh we're not going to search for little
green men and i got a couple quotes up
here that are not worth going into
but this pretty much at this point
nasa's like all right look we're done we
are not gonna risk
you know nasa's gotta go to the congress
for its funding they just it was too hot
a topic
they kept getting beaten up so you know
it's understandable why they kind of
backed off from it
um uh but then what of course happens in
the 90s
is there's the mars rock that is found
in
antarctica which seems to indicate that
maybe there was
fossil life on mars now we don't really
think that's true anymore but it started
people really thinking
about astrobiology in the solar system
and then of course uh as we're going to
talk about exoplanets were discovered
so um as i say so so you know congress
wanted to kill seti because it you know
worked for getting votes
but nature and science had other plans
so
i want to talk about three revolutions
that brought astrobiology back
into the fore and of course astrobiology
is the study of life
in a cosmic or particularly planetary
context
um so the first was the discovery in
1995 of
exoplanets planets orbiting sun-like
stars
not pulsars because pulsar pulsar
planets were discovered earlier
but you know stars that you could
imagine having life
occur and you know as i said you can see
aristotle and democritus
beating each other up over the question
of whether there were other planets
orbiting other stars
2 500 years ago and in 1995 the question
gets definitively answered that's pretty
amazing
and so then things like the kepler
mission just starts finding
um uh uh planets wholesale exoplanets
wholesale
and so you know now we have lot we know
about we know
about 4000 uh exoplanets for sure
and we can do the statistics of them so
we know about really in some sense we
know even
more about even more exoplanets and we
found lots of exoplanets that are
potentially habitable or in the right
place
where you know water liquid you could
pour liquid water on the surface and it
would just sit there if you had an
atmosphere
um so you know we've learned quite a bit
the second revolution is we have now
sent robot
probes to every type of solar system
object
out there right every planet has been
visited we've visited asteroids we've
visited comets we've visited
you know you name it um and in
particular uh
mars is entirely inhabited by robots
mars is a robot planet um so
uh they've been wandering those robots
have been wandering around taking
amazing pictures
uh like this one right if i showed you
this picture and didn't tell you where
it was from you might say oh that's
tunisia that's the desert somewhere
but no it's mars and by studying the
these ex these other planet planets in
our solar system excuse me
in detail we've learned things like mars
was probably a blue world once
maybe not for very long but um we now
have you know conclusive evidence that
mars had
you know a lot of water on it for a
while
rushing water um so you know there's a
great example of climate change there
right mars used to be almost used to
have enough to be warm enough and to
have enough atmosphere to have liquid
water on its surface
now it's a frozen dry hell so um yeah
there you go
now the third revolution uh is embodied
in this picture and i'd like to have
when i show this picture i like to ask
people
which one of these is the earth right
and so you can look at that for a minute
and think about it and of course it's a
trick question because
they're all earth right earth what we
now have learned from earth's
uh study of earth its deep history is
that the earth has been many planets
across its lifetime
in the beginning uh it was a malt it had
a molten uh
ocean uh during the hadiyan period and
then later on it was a water world once
you know the cooled enough water
condensed and there were there really
weren't continents yet there were sort
of proto-continents so it was a water
world
at some points the earth has been so hot
there's been no ice anywhere on it
except maybe a
mountaintops um so it was a jungle world
at other points it was all ice it was
almost entirely glaciated to be a
snowball world and then of course there
here's our happy version of the earth
now
but unfortunately in about a billion
years uh as the sun warms up
earth will become the oceans will boil
away and
uh so you know cash your bitcoin in now
man because it's not gonna last okay
so from these three revolutions even
though we haven't discovered life
anywhere else yet
we have learned so much about how life
and planets can interact
that we are now prepared we know how to
search
for life in the universe so okay what
does what does
the exoplanet revolution and these other
other revolutions change about
uh seti and thinking about um
life intelligent life in the universe
well the first thing is we now have data
new data for the drake equation right so
remember this is the drake equation
uh when drake wrote this down only the
first term
r sub star the rate of star formation
was known now we know
for sure you know really nailed the
statistics of f sub p
and n sub e uh and what we know from
these is an amazing fact
every star you see in the sky pretty
much
has a planet probably a family of
planets and if you count up five of them
one of them is going to have a planet in
the right place for life to form in the
habitable zone
so that's new information and you can
use that woody sullivan and i use that
to try and rearrange the drake equation
to see well okay now what can we say
about um the probabilities etc for
life and you know really what comes out
of this is we now know that in the
habitable in the observable universe
there are 10 to the 22 you planets
habitable zone planets not just planets
but habitable zone planets
that's 10 billion trillion planets so if
you just want to do a simple
frequentist kind of model for the
probability it means that
okay the only way that we're alone in
the universe
is if the probability of forming a
civilization
per habitable zone planet is less than
one in 10
billion trillion okay that's a pretty
small number now of course you could say
well what do i judge it against well you
can judge it against other
are you know people been arguing about
this for a while and that number is way
smaller
than anybody would have said beforehand
right so so people
what this means is what i mean by this
is that people who in
10 years ago 20 years ago were were
thinking that they were
they were pessimists because they had
some number uh you know for this
uh uh how unlikely life was you know the
actual number turns out to be so much
lower than that that they were actually
optimists
they would have said there were no uh
civilizations in the universe
and now that we know what this kind of
probability should look like there would
they would actually have predicted
millions billions
of of habitable or not habitable of
civilizations
so we can go back into this later if
somebody wants to but you know that's
that's one way in which this new
information actually changed seti
but more than that what really changes
is that now
because of exoplanets you know exactly
where to look
right and you know exactly what to look
for
you know i'm not just randomly choosing
stars i'm choosing a star
that has a planet in the habitable zone
i'm going to stare at that guy
for as long as possible so let me talk a
little bit more about that
because that brings us into the idea of
biosignatures
right so so this is just remarkable i
mean
we could go on for hours about how
unbelievably remarkable this is
when the one of the main ways we detect
exoplanets is when
the exoplanet if uh the orbit is right
that the exoplanet passes in front of
its star it does a little mini eclipse
of the star
and there is a moment there when the
when that's happening
so here's a diagram of this you see the
star that's the yellow
you see the planet that's the black but
this little white halo
that's the atmosphere if the planet has
an atmosphere there's going to be
a you know a brief window when the light
from the star passes through the
atmosphere
and as we do all the time in astronomy
we can use the the imprint the the the
fingerprints
uh of the elements that get absorbed
that absorb light in that atmosphere
uh usually we do it for interstellar
clouds but now we can do it in this
this exoplanet's atmosphere to tell
what's in the atmosphere
so we can we can get markers for what
kind of chemicals
are in the atmosphere and we believe
there are certain chemicals
that would own or molecules that would
only be in the atmosphere if
life was there the er example of this is
oxygen
the only reason there's oxygen in the
earth's atmosphere is because of life
microbes basically pardon my language
farted
oxygen into the atmosphere to create the
oxygen we breathe today
if life disappeared from earth the
oxygen after a relatively short time
would all react away and be gone
so we believe that oxygen and methane
both in the atmosphere
could be a very good bio signature but
people
you know there's this huge effort
searching for
uh you know trying to characterize okay
what biosignature should we look like
look for excuse me and so here's
actually the earth through time
this is uh age if you go down here and
this these lines here are the
concentration of various
chemicals in the atmosphere so if you
just look at this diagram on the
left and go down let's look at uh oxygen
you see that in the beginning four
billion years ago there was hardly any
oxygen
and then over time the oxygen rose in
what's called the great oxidation event
and then rose again to the level that we
have now
right and there's other elements in here
that you can see changing over time
so that means that if we looked at a
planet if someone was looking at us
uh billions of years ago during what's
called the archaean phase
there and they looked at the spectra so
this is the the
intensity of radiation uh versus
wavelength they would see a bunch of
dips a bunch of chemical fingerprints
from you know various elements that
would tell you that oh yeah there
were some there was some early life
there by the time you got to what's
called the proto uh the proterozoic
earth
some of those had changed you've got new
um uh bio signatures in it and the
modern earth has a whole range of things
that if you could observe
it you would say wow for sure that that
planet has a
biosphere that planet has a robust you
know uh uh
set of network of living things that
have completely changed the planet
um so over the past 15 20 years people
have really dug into what we could call
biosignature science
and here's this great paper if anybody's
interested in it that has like some of
the superstars of this field
um and you know people are really
thinking deeply about well how do we go
after biosignatures you know first of
all what produces life
what you know uh how could a dead planet
fool us into thinking
that it had bio signatures no matter
what our data is always going to be
somewhat limited how do we interpret
limited data
and how do we quantify how certain we
are if we think we find
a biosignature because this is going to
come back later i want to say
you know if somebody makes a claim that
they found a bio signature
you can bet they're going to get their
their butts kicked
by other scientists as they should to
see
you know the standards of evidence are
going to have to be very high you can't
claim
that you've detected life unless your
evidence is going to be extraordinary
and you know people are preparing for
that
so okay so bio signatures are about
i'm sorry to say this because i love
microbes but it's about dumb life
right what about smart life well that's
techno signatures so remember that you
know sort of
nasa had gotten gun shy uh from doing
anything doing you're really diving into
um uh intelligent life because of what
had happened but then in 2018 remarkably
congress actually
added to the budget a requirement that
nasa should study techno signatures
and so nasa then called a meeting uh in
houston uh
and i was lucky enough to be at that
meeting and everybody was like
oh my god you know like nasa's asking us
what should we do if we were going to
study techno signatures and it was a
great meeting it was
so much excitement and ideas were just
flown everywhere it was really it was
one of the most fun meetings i've ever
been at
and out of this came this uh uh this
report that jason wright uh and others
spearheaded
and we all contributed but jason jason
is the man um
uh and uh did uh you know uh was the
first author on it but
like i said there was uh there were also
women of course you know uh
as well so it was you know an amazing
group of people who came together
to to do it um so you can read that
report
um and uh uh what came one of the things
that came out of that was systematic
thinking it was the beginning
of systematic thinking so sophia sheik
who is
you know a graduate student but what i
consider you know she's you know one tip
of the spear of the next generation
of of um seti or techno signature
thinkers
came up with this idea after listening
to the the talks about the idea well we
need figures of merit we need some way
of judging
if i propose a techno signature how do
we know whether that's worthwhile going
after and so
she proposed this uh these this figure
of merit
nine uh nine axes of merit for example
can the search only be done in the far
future or can it be done now with
existing telescopes
uh will the techno signature be
short-lived or long-lived will it be
ambiguous or unambiguous etc
so you know we can go down this but we
don't need to now the main thing was
it was the beginning of trying of you
know starting to have
uh you know bright young scientists um
uh like sophia
you know creating a community uh to
really revitalize
how do you think about this problem and
especially now that you've got
exoplanets to look at
how do you think about this problem how
to be systematic uh
about the scientific search um and then
remarkably
uh nasa funded a uh techno signature
techno signature so we put together a
team i was the pi on this one
um and uh we asked for two years of
funding to do to to categorize
atmospheric techno signatures and and
that grant was funded and we're now
putting in
these these are the people who are part
of we're about to renew it i i think
we've been very successful i'll show you
some results
i'd like to i think you know like to
argue we were successful but that was
this was a
a watershed moment and uh now there's
been a few other techno signature grants
that have been awarded so it's great
you know the ball is beginning to roll
and then there's also breakthrough
listen which funded uh to the tune of
100 million dollars
uh the renewal of radio seti as well so
you know really feels like uh you know
something has changed
so let's talk about techno signatures
what are examples of techno signatures
um particularly the techno signatures
that are going to be associated with
exoplanets
so i'm going to run through these
quickly and then i'm going to talk about
them a little bit more
there are the possibility of seeing city
lights or heat islands on planets
there's the large scale deployment of
solar panels on
planets or moons there are atmospheric
pollutants things that shouldn't show up
in an atmosphere unless there's industry
going on uh and then there's everyone's
favorite orbiting megastructures who
doesn't want to say the word orbiting
megastructure okay so um this figure
actually shows
it kind of you know gives you a little
graphical representation this is a big
grant that we put in an icar grant to
nasa that uh
jason um wright spearheaded it didn't
get funded but hopefully
next time we'll put it in again um but
here you kind of see everything you see
the city lights you see some orbiting
mega structures
but let's go into in a more detail so
alien mega structures is the idea it's
kind of like a dyson sphere but instead
of a dyson sphere
think of it more of as a swarm you've
got like you know lots of
large orbiting uh objects orbiting the
star
you know perhaps collecting solar energy
now the amazing thing about this is we
almost thought we saw one right with uh
boy ion star
this is the transit data um uh for by
ion star and you see it it's it's
if you know what transits for planets
look like this doesn't look like it at
all
it had all of this irregular short um
uh drops in the light making it look
like the star
was being orbited by a bunch of blobs
and so when the
you know um when they wrote the paper on
this they you know
gave a bunch of possibilities uh most
all of them natural except
the possibility for alien megastructures
which of course made huge news
everybody was excited about it and you
know we all knew
that you know probably that's an
extraordinary claim it's probably not
what's going to be what's happening
but it was the beginning of being
willing to say you know getting past the
giggle factor look of course
we have to consider this you know we'll
probably rule it out but at some point
we may not be able to rule it out
right okay so alien mega structures one
type of techno signature city lights and
heat islands
so there are telescopes on the drawing
board now
that may be able to map uh the features
of an exoplanet for
looking for uh just even continents
right so this is a
work by berdunya and kuhn where this is
imagine look at this this is
this would be the map this would
actually be the map of a planet with its
continents
and by uh with things like the extremely
large telescope
you would be able to recover you know a
version of this you'd actually be able
to make
out you know the the the basic contours
of the map
and if you're using infrared if there
are city lights
if there are heat islands from industry
you might be able to make those out too
so that's really exciting i mean this is
obviously next generation kinds of stuff
but even with jwst there was a recent
paper that showed that you know if
they're
if the city lights are coming are in a
narrow band if they're emitting like
sodium lamps
where you know it's a single frequency
you might be able to see them so even
even
uh new technologies that are going to
get launched soon
you might be able to see them another
possibility is look if you cover
a lot of your planet or a moon with
solar panels
um uh lingam and loeb uh showed that you
would be able to
uh the reflection the reflect you would
actually see
the imprint of all of the solar panels
in the reflected light
um so and regardless of which uh um
which kind of uh material you use they
all would have
they would all imprint a signature in
the reflected light
this is something that came from our
group that we just did uh this was uh
jacob hawk
mizrah led this effort um and this was
i'm really excited about we looked at
chlorofluorocarbons right with that
cfcs that's the stuff that you know
damages the ozone
um but it's a it's a chemical that you
know it's very hard to imagine that
nature would produce cfcs on its own
it's
really a unusual you know kind of
molecule
and so what um uh jacob and ravi did is
they ran
climate models where they put in various
levels of cfcs into the climate model
from exactly what we have now up to 100
times
more they ran the model allowed the you
know the everything to sort of
equilibrate
and then they took spectra they they
they made it they took synthetic spectra
as if they were observing it from a
distance
using the jwst or using you know more
advanced telescopes that are on the
drawing boards
and what they found was and you can see
this here these dotted lines here the
blue line the red dotted line the black
dotted line
the signature of the cfc stands out it's
just
way it's it's clear that it's there in
fact
what we found was that with the jwst
we would be able to detect earth levels
of chlorofluorocarbons
using um uh you know using the jwst
this is a milestone for seti because
what it means is is that using
earth-based technology that we have now
we would be able to
detect another earth now this was uh for
uh i think it was the trappist
uh system that we were looking at and um
i won't go into the detail in this line
let me just note again talking about
standards of evidence
no signal is considered to be a a
uh uh detection of anything whether it's
a
particles you know the higgs boson or
something like you know the
chlorofluorocarbon in an atmosphere
unless you get above a signal to noise
ratio of five that's what that so
anything above this
uh would be a detection and what this
red line here shows you that with just a
hundred
hours um of in this case this was the
origin space telescope with just a
hundred hours of origin space telescope
time
you would be able to character you'd be
able to find
um uh you'd be able to detect cfcs
at the earth concentrations that's down
here um so it's really remarkable and in
fact it would require
less time than a than a biosignature
there's some biosignatures that would
take longer time
so this was really you know this is
going through referee hood now hopefully
it'll survive the referee
i believe it will uh but this is this is
you know this really kind of shows you
where we're at right now we're really
starting to
you know start running in terms of
characterizing what possible techno
signatures
to look for how to look for them what
their detectability is etc
okay so um uh let's talk a little bit
about other kinds of systematic thinking
about techno signatures
um you know because that's really where
the field is we're now since we're just
beginning we gotta
we have to do more than just propose
techno signatures and characterize them
we have to ask ourselves some basic
questions like what is the expected age
of a civilization that we might likely
detect
is there really a fermi paradox how
common will techno signatures be what is
their lifetimes
so let's just talk a little bit about
this briefly so there's been this belief
in general that a prior what you might
call a prior people sort of have this
belief that well you know
there will be fewer techno signatures
than bio signatures and in general
they're going to be short-lived
um and the reason people usually sort of
just sort of feel this intuitively
is because well you figure like you know
the earth's biosphere has been around
four billion years but the techno
signatures just popped up
right so there's sort of the sense of
like well yeah you know techno
signatures they're going to be shorter
lived
um uh but that's really not true when
you think about it there are
two papers well there's this paper that
uh balbi and
serkovic did longevity is the key to the
search for techno signatures and right
now our group is
you know right in the midst of writing a
a paper called the case for techno
signatures
why they may be more abundant long-lived
highly highly detectable and unambiguous
and the reason for this is that techno
signatures can
are you don't they're they're freed they
can they can be freed from the bios
the biospheres which produce them right
a technosphere meaning the you know if
you imagine a biosphere is the sum total
of um
life uh the technosphere is what an
intelligent civilization
how it would wrap the planet in
technology like we're doing now with our
satellites etc
but the thing is a technosphere is not a
techno signature
right a single civilization could
produce
ice right 10x here meaning fill in your
x could produce millions
billions of techno signatures imagine
that a civilization sends out
uh probes you know to go explore the the
universe
every one of those probes is a techno
signature that could be detected by us
it's going to be sending signals back
and forth
um you know that we might be able to
detect so you know a single civilization
can produce many many techno signatures
and each one of those techno signatures
could have enormous lifetimes
the civilization could die after a
thousand years and the techno signatures
could go on for another million
10 billion years who knows right i mean
we know it just depends
if we were to coat the moon in uh
solar panels it would take a lo and we
died and we disappeared the reflectance
you know that that would show up for
quite a long time i mean the only thing
that would destroy that was the
you know was micro meteorite uh uh
impacts on the
so really you know there's there's
arguments to be made that techno
signatures may be more prevalent more
long-lived
than biosignatures so the two aspects
are very complementary
and they don't need the techno
signatures don't need to be tied
to the species that created them they
can be freed from them because that's
what intelligence and technology do
all right to conclude here i've got
another four or five or you know four to
ten minutes let me just talk about the
fermi paradox again the first thing i
want to say is
there is no indirect fermi paradox right
so the idea that of the of the
the indirect fermi paradoxes we've
looked and we haven't seen
but in fact we haven't looked people
have this idea that like you know
you know people are looking for uh
intelligent life astronomers every night
every night astronomers are
you know turning their radio telescopes
to the sky looking for signatures
of intelligent life there was never any
money to do that so
so um uh uh uh jason wright
bo and collaborators working off an idea
from jill tarter actually
calculated we looked at all the steady
searches that have ever been done and
calculated how much of the parameter
space
that needs to be searched has been
searched uh and if that parameter space
was an
ocean the amount that we've actually
looked at was a hot tub
so if you looked at a hot tub and didn't
find any dolphins in the hot tub would
you then say
there's no dolphins in the ocean so as
of right now
you know there is no direct or sorry
indirect fermi paradox we just have not
looked well enough to really say
anything about the prevalence or or lack
thereof
of intelligent life now the uh for mo
that should be for me
uh the direct fermi paradox the one
about why haven't you why
why didn't they show up here and create
a civilization that we should have
evidence for well that's a little bit
harder
and my group um uh led by jonathan uh uh
carol nellenbach
um along with jason and caleb scharf we
uh
built some simulation software to do
this and here's a model that we ran
where uh that white dot there is going
to be a single uh
uh abiogenesis event that's gonna create
life
which will send probes out and here
you're gonna watch the galaxy
so uh the blue are stars and at some
point that there you go
that's the wave that is the settlement
wave and you see that it very quickly
spreads across the galaxy there's really
no way we played with this
you know we had the computer technology
to be able to really do what are called
agent-based models of this
and it turns out there's almost no way
to hold that wave back
so you know in that sense the fermi
paradox the direct fermi paradox
is more of a problem however what nobody
ever considered was
after that wave passes you're now in a
steady state
right so you should have a steady state
uh uh fraction of habitable plan of of
sorry of
planets that have a technological
civilization but if civilizations don't
last forever and there's no reason why
they should
then that changes things that means
you're gonna have civilizations die and
then you know have to be reseeded etc so
here is a simulation that we did
where we had a finite lifetime for the
settlement and each of those different
colors
is a a a a civilization and its
daughters
that are being produced and what you see
is here depending on the parameters
you get pockets of civilization and
settlement happening
but because the civilizations only last
a million years or so
they don't spread everywhere and it
depends on how the stars are moving
relative to each other the density of
stars
but in this case you can have that
settlement wave have passed over
but you can still have places in the
galaxy perhaps us
where there just hasn't been any uh
civilizations for a long long long time
or ever
you know so um that's actually i think a
very interesting point and it's you know
just shows you how
the the the revitalization of the entire
seti debate things that were talked
about a long time ago
are now being revitalized because we
have the capacities the computer
technologies etc to study them
all right so what does this mean for us
so we know that we're in the midst of
the anthropocene human beings are now
the dominant force
geologically in terms of shaping the
behavior of the what we call the coupled
earth systems
um and so you know one of the things
that you can really ask
is you know if as we start thinking
about other civilizations how does that
reflect back on what's happening to us
now because
clearly you know uh climate change and
the anthropocene could be a terminal
could be terminal for us
human beings aren't going to go extinct
but we could put you know this kind of
global civilization this project of
civilization
that we've been at for the last 10 000
years it could put it out of business
perhaps for a very very long time if the
climate really changes dramatically
so you know one of the questions that
comes from thinking about uh
this is i i like to call it the
astrobiology of the anthropocene and
this is what
my book the uh um light of the stars is
about
is it allows you to reframe what's
happening to us right now in terms of
in general asking what are the
trajectories of civilizations right are
there rules
for any civilization that forms anywhere
are there rules for the development
because in some sense
a civilization is just a kind of a
machine for harvesting energy
it harvests energy from the planet and
it uses
that energy to do useful work which is
to do the things that a civilization
does
and the second law of thermodynamics
tells you like look man when you do that
you're going to generate waste you're
going to generate entropy in lots of
different forms
and that you know may set rules for you
in terms of what is possible for the
evolution
of planets and it may be that everybody
has an anthropocene
right and the smart civilizations are
the ones that
recognize it and change their behavior
learn how to come into some kind of
equilibrium with uh their
their biospheres and the dumb ones are
the ones that like are like yeah it'll
be fine don't worry about it
um so yeah which which category do we
fall into time will tell
uh and then with this one of the things
i think that's interesting about this is
how it changes remember the kardashev
scale
really changes how you think about the
kardashev scale right because the
kardashev scale for planets at least
the type one civilization was a
civilization it was only based on energy
consumption right
a type one planet would use all the
power
available to it from solar energy but
this was typical
1960s kind of like white guy thinking
about planets right it's like if i have
enough energy i will rule my planet
but what we learned from the
anthropocene was that uh you know
planets yeah you got to be careful with
that right you know it's the planets
have their own
their own ways of doing things right you
can't uh you can't bring a planet to
heal
right so uh i call now when i think
about type one planets i think of them
as
planetary brutalism they very much came
out of that moment
you know that like i said sort of
emerges from the thinking and the
enlightenment that like you know
planets are just dead things life is
just you know a bunch of atoms doing
whatever they're doing
they really didn't understand the
complexity of life and this is something
we have to learn
you know sort of you know in general we
have to learn from all the other
cultures
on the earth that there's other ways to
view life uh and the you know the
intricacy of
of life as a network and this um
yeah right so you can't bring planets to
heal but you might be able to bring them
you might be able to bring up bring a
plan to them and i'm not going to go
into this but there's a paper i wrote
about the idea of thinking about how
what i call the five classes of planet
really thinking about entropy
right i think entropy and dissipation
are a critical way
of understanding planets and any planet
that's long-lived is going to have to
have solved their anthropocene problem
uh and that there may be you know uh
rules for that that both we have to
learn
and may be useful for searching for
clients okay my last few minutes
finally ufos and uaps right so
um as brian noted uh a few week uh yeah
it was
really only a few weeks ago i wrote an
op-ed for the new york times
i know i don't get to choose the title
uh but actually this title i was okay
with uh
i'm a physicist who searches for aliens
ufos don't impress me and what i really
meant was
the data associated with linking ufos to
aliens to exo civilizations come on
we're just you know
um you know any claim about alien life
has to have the same
standards of evidence that my colleagues
and i are going to be held to
um when it comes to techno signatures so
there's no free ride that comes here and
they're just that data isn't there
so um let me state very clearly though
the uh
uap stuff the uh what is it unidentified
aerial phenomena
it's definitely of interest there's some
you know interesting stuff there it
should be studied openly
it should be studied scientifically um
i'm all in favor of that
right okay so don't box me to some
people because really after i my twitter
you i got suddenly i got on the ufo
twitter's radar because of this and it
was not fun there was something intended
yeah right there's some you know people
were you know really cool and there were
other people who were just like
it didn't matter you know no matter no
investigation was ever going to show
that
uips were not associated with aliens but
again it's about standards
of evidence i just want to leave you
with this what i call the hierarchy of
extraordinary claims right
because this is the way it sort of works
for for
you know the claims of ufos being
associated with aliens like
okay the claim that that they want us to
believe people are like yes
absolutely ufos are aliens is that so
the claim is we are being visited by
advanced alien life that can cross
interstellar space
but somehow can't manage to stay hidden
right you know
so you know all right that's an
extraordinary claim there's there's huge
amounts of extraordinary claims there
but what those people have to understand
is that you know
i can take one step back and i still
have an extraordinary claim we're being
visited by an advanced alien life
that can cross interstellar space well
you know that claim would require
extraordinary evidence and i can take
another step back there are
advanced alien life there there is
advanced alien life
that can cross interstellar space we
don't know that interstellar space can
be crossed like by biological
creatures i mean just you know the
distances between the stars are
incredible so that itself would require
extraordinary evidence
but i can take a step even further back
there are advanced alien life or there
is advanced alien life
that would be a game-changing monumental
find right
that requires extraordinary evidence and
then finally all the way down
there's life there's life in the
universe that itself
is so remarkable that it requires
extraordinary evidence so like the idea
that you can just
jump this you know somehow with a bunch
of fuzzy blobs and and personal
testimony
you know we're gonna just so like i said
study it get a data set that's
worthwhile and then we can see where
where it leads but as of right now that
is just too large a claim
using the data you have to be able to
make all right
so i just want to end by noting wow carl
sagan you know when i wrote the book
uh you know uh carl sagan was everywhere
i wouldn't i couldn't believe how many
places carl sagan
showed up in not only thinking about
aliens but think about earth history
planetary science you name it
it was just it's remarkable so i just
want to you know mad props to
carl sagan he's one of the few although
someday we'll have one for you i'm sure
adam will have a finger puppet a finger
puppet yes and i'm delighted to have
and someday i'll put links to my
interview with andrew ian
and carl's daughter sasha sagan which
were highlights of my
into the impossible career he is
certainly a hero to millions around the
world maybe
billions and billions as he would say
billions of billions of people
all right so that's it thank you very
much for your time i appreciate it
this is wonderful so we got a huge host
of people over 100 people
watching live and many will watch later
but you know you snooze you lose
you have to be ali in tuning alien if
you want to catch things live and ask
questions
uh we have a bunch of questions adam
first of all thank you so much that was
really fascinating
i i really believe that you and your
colleagues are some of the most
innovative thinkers
and one thing to note that gives me hope
is that you know a few years back
you know trying to propose that a
professor should be hired
at a major university like university of
rochester or
at uc san diego would have been laughed
off and we have
professor shelly wright here who is uh
one of the foremost leaders
in the nascent field of looking for
optical signal sirs from seti
instrumentation i hope to have her on
the podcast uh once we
can meet in public and don't have to
wear masks or meet in person
but hopefully that'll be soon she's a
good friend amazing scientist look for
that soon she has a ted talk
actually that you can find where she was
in a prison i believe but that uh that
shouldn't stop us
i have a question just by people
assemble i want to ask people to leave
your questions
in the live chat if you're watching live
and uh if you catch us afterwards you
can leave
a chat a question in the comment section
and then adam and i can maybe go back
and answer those questions later
but for now i always have a question
this is the 60th anniversary of the
drake equation
actually uh frank put it together in
1961 i'm hoping to have him on the
podcast that'll be great fun
and you know i always think of that as
an equation quote unquote in that
you know if one of our students one of
our billion undergraduates in rochester
san diego hands in a paper and it's got
a number
and there's no uncertainty there's no
error analysis there's no propagation
of errors associated how would you
handle that in other words
is it a paradigm is it actually an
equation is it just kind of a framework
to think about things because as i
have often said you know this is not the
way that we you and i spend our days
looking at the error analysis not the
actual
average value or expected value yeah i
mean it's it's a framework right i mean
it's not a law
of nature it was a way and that's what
made it important so i understand when
people are like
you know you can't take this thing too
far but you can use it it was always a
framework as
as jill tarter says for understanding
our uncertainties i mean what we don't
know
it was a way it was a way of breaking
the problem up rationally
so that you could focus on individual
pieces so yeah it's not
you know people shouldn't take it for
for more than it is
it was a brilliant uh formulation of the
field
it was you know it laid out how the
field should be done but you know
there's mathematically there's only so
much you know
that you can do with it there's going to
be other ways that you're going to have
to think if you want to really derive
you want to divide derive quantitative
results there's other things you're
going to have to do bayesian statistics
other kinds of approaches so a question
from one of my
audience members optimus phoenix prime
uh so this is a transformer in arizona
presumably
optimus is asking do you expect that uh
people would travel do you expect that
you would have alien artificial
intelligence
uh what do you think is more likely to
be in the
actual zeitgeist the you know kind of
floating around and
and so forth what would be most probable
assuming that they could make this huge
traverse across the eerie gap as an
eerie silence as paul davies has said on
the show
you know that's a great question and you
know
so much of it depends on sort of you
know what's possible with technology i'm
not a great believer
in you know the idea of downloading your
consciousness
into machines i don't think really
understand consciousness anywhere near
that
um but you know it does make sense
you're gonna send machines just you know
and then
send signals back because the distances
are so vast
um you know i love thinking about as
much as i love warp drives i love warp
drives as much as the next guy but um
i'm always interested in what happens if
you are
limited to the laws of physics we
understand now
um so there's great science fiction by
was alistair reynolds
uh his um uh uh i can't remember
revelation space where everybody has to
travel you know
they use uh um you know uh hibernation
to move around and such so you know a
lot of it just depends on the technology
that is possible but if i had to guess
i would think that yeah in general
you're gonna use um
you know you'd use robots because it's
just it's much easier
yeah andy weir who is a recent guest on
the podcast has a new book project hail
mary
where he envisions an encounter with uh
with an astronaut who wakes up after
hibernating himself for many many
perhaps decades
uh or more to save not only planet earth
but the
observable portion of our universe uh
one of my good friends and listeners
loyal listeners
um nuno mariko from portugal he's saying
you know would they send a program in
other words would they send kind of like
inverse independence day where we upload
on a us
luckily they had a usb c a adapter
on the freaking spacecraft but luckily
but you know would they send a program
would they send something to do
something rather than just like we're
here a message
would there actually be you know a
blockchain you know would it be
something that you could actually do
something with
um that would be observable and and
decryptable even from the
from the background that otherwise would
appear as noise i think that could be
very hard you know one of my favorite
movies
uh um science fiction movies is a rival
right because
you know a rival starts off with you
know they send two people in to talk to
these aliens one is a physicist a kind
of carl sagan physicist the other one's
a linguist and the physicist is like
i'm gonna show them pie and we're gonna
learn each other's math and then we're
gonna be able to talk to each other
which has been the standard trope
um and it fails miserably right and it's
only the linguist
who you know understands how language
actually works who's able to develop
communications we just had a lovely talk
we have a regular series
uh a techno signature series that uh
robbie kapoor who
runs and today we had an anthropologist
um
talking to us and just the idea of how
different
alien minds could be i i i doubt
seriously that
that there's going to be this easy
exchange of you know programming and
everything i mean i think it would take
a long time
if it's even possible to really decipher
you know the languages and such um so i
don't think they could just send a
program and we'd be able to upload it i
mean there'd be a lot a lot of
difficulty with that
fascinating idea alien minds fascinating
idea
the next question comes from a young and
up-and-coming scientist by the name of
david brynn
uh here at uc san diego phd he's going
to do something with his life
yes i think he's an up and coming yeah i
think i think we better watch him
uh so he talks about um how in a 1983
paper he talked about the lifespan of
colonized
star systems and their settlements and
whether or not that wave of colonization
might burn itself
out you know if you do the volterra
equation
and you don't put any limitation on the
amount of prey the predators grow
unbounded you know can the same thing
happen in your galactic
you know wave that it can basically run
out of control if you don't put on some
boundary conditions in terms of
you know how much actual energy it can
be extracted how many
you know beings would be there i guess
is the sense of his question well
basically you know we do that so what
this is an agent-based model so the the
nice thing about this is it's it's not
differential equations it's algorithmic
not um you know not not analytical so
um you know the really you just relied
on the you know of course there's
assumptions about you know each agent
each you know
an agent is a settled system that has a
certain time to send the next one
out uh next probe out you know so
there's our list of parameters
associated with it but really we didn't
see anything that could stop the the
settlement wave it would sweep across
what
could happen is depending on like say
the probe
your how far your probe can get before
it breaks right so if that's short
then you'll have lots of settlement in
the center of the galaxy but as you get
to the edges of the galaxy with the
stars the interstellar distance is
larger
then that can sort of uh slow down but
the uh
jason wright's great insight was that
the halo stars you've got these stars
from the halo that are just on these
plunging orbits
that they you know a civilization could
you know wait for one of those to come
through
jump on one and then you know ride to an
entirely different part of the galaxy
uh and then start the settlement wave
again so we just found that it was
and we tried right we it was very hard
to stop that settlement wave
yeah so another question is coming um
from a listener by the name of prince
charming that's pretty cool
shout out to the royal family is it
possible to detect nightside lights
on exoplanets well this is yeah i think
this is one of the great frontiers and
there was just a paper by avi loeb and a
collaborator
um that sort of showed again that if it
was even jwst
if you had um uh uh lights that were
emitting
you know all of their energy in a single
wavelength it would be possible
to detect that um and then also as i
said with this next generation
of telescopes where you actually might
be able to get some mapping of surface
features
um yes you would be able to see you have
the possibility of seeing it so you know
as i always like to point out this is a
long game right i mean you know the
science as i was like science is very
exciting and it's also unbelievably
boring
because you know to to find out anything
extraordinary takes incredible amounts
of work
and so you know the uh it's going to
take 10 20 30 40 years
to get this data but remember this is
the first time after 2
500 years we're going to have data we're
not just yelling at each other anymore
we're going to have data relevant
to this question of life and intelligent
life in the universe so
all of these things are are now becoming
possible and we're just setting sail
we're just like we're getting in the
boats
and we're heading off starting this
adventure yeah one of my listeners is
loyal listener andy oates is asking a
question i get in different forms in
other words
maybe the reason that we're not seeing
them or any evidence is that they're
using
such advanced technology physics you
know ignoring the tic tacs and
and other sightings and bokehs and stuff
like that but actual you know the
lack of the answer to the fermi paradox
is just that they're using such advanced
technology
that they have no reason to uh we have
no reason to expect we can even interact
with it any more
than an ant colony could understand you
know uh
su 3 cross sc2 cross u1 right
that's that's a good point and it's
possible you know it's it's entirely
possible that's just and you know
what we just you know if after i mean
this is in some sense like what's going
on with dark matter right now right
people
we're now you know sort of well into
searches for dark matter people are not
finding anything
at some point you get you know you reach
the point where you're like okay
everything we understand about the
you know weak interactions that may just
you know tells us
that okay we've explored all the
parameter space and then you have to go
somewhere else
in terms of your thinking about this and
that may be if after you know 200 years
of searching we didn't find anything
we'd either be left with there's nobody
out there or
you know or we're going to have to
really rethink about how we search but
the nice thing is
like there's certain laws of physics
like the second law of thermodynamics
that's really hard to get away from i
mean i just you know as there's a reason
why the patent office does not take
any perpetual motion machine patents
anymore yeah i got the last one in
i slipped the last one under that goal
poster
a couple of our questions here from the
brilliant into the impossible audience
there is no more brilliant audience in
all the world
uh or the known universe as far as we
know um
so there's a question is there a
possibility nuno is asking again
that maybe they're staying away from us
they're avoiding us some aliens and
that's the reason the fermi paradox is
answered in the
in the negative because they know we're
violent and that they see
everything we've done you know uh and
maybe maybe before you answer that
uh adam i'll take a digression because i
know you're capable of answering all
these questions
uh what do you think would happen the
day after you or your colleagues were
successful let's do a gdunkan experiment
you succeed alien biosignature techno
signature what have you whatever form
you like
it could be lights it could be global
warming type phenomena
um and you uh the next day because there
are some that say
you know and it's it's ten sigma
confirmed
you know peer-reviewed published in the
new york post and the nature journal
uh so so we can really believe it uh
you can't believe until it's published
in the major yeah right
so uh my question to you is what do you
think what happened the next day in
other words
and that'll dovetail back into nuno's
question i promise i think
i think it would i think would be
profound i think there would be you know
the next day
the next year the next 10 years i mean
the recognition
that we were not alone i think even if
we weren't getting messages i still
think it would revolutionize philosophy
religion
we'd have to deal with the fact that
like this was happening life
was a force in the universe that had
managed to appear somewhere else
because if you get two there's no reason
now you got to start thinking the
universe is full of life right
so i think it would be profound now
after you know there's obviously a
certain limit to what you can do with
this right so i don't i think
know it's not like human beings would
suddenly become super peaceful and we'd
all live you know
uh you know um uh lovely law i mean
we'd still be people right it's not
gonna transform we'd probably still have
wars and such but
it would really really fundamentally
alter how we think of ourselves
um and then of course what's going to
happen is we're going to start sending
probes if it's if it's 10 year light
years away
you can bet we're going to start
figuring out how to send probes at it
and
which is interesting to think about
whether or not people have sent probes
at us
you know that's one place where you can
sort of you know are there are there's
is there stuff lying around in the
universe from because you know earth has
had bio signatures for billions of years
yeah somebody throw something at us
right and there's you know a place where
like you know i don't you know the ufo
stuff
but like you know are there is there
stuff in the in the uh
the solar system that's something you
should think about yeah yeah we had a
talk with uh paul davies and greg
benford right before the pandemic and
they talked about lurkers and
workers uh you know there's something on
the moon or on
one of these um trojan asteroid belts
but the reason i asked you know the
preferatory question to nino's question
about them avoiding us because we're too
violent
in my own pers in my impression you know
if you go down to the beach here
in san diego and you scoop up some water
there's trillions and trillions and
trillions of examples of life
and uh we're pretty good at
exterminating a lot of that life
including advanced life bonobos and
orangutans um
and and so forth as jane goodall winner
of the templeton prize this year is
documented
and you know so i feel no no necessary
difference would really persist if we
knew about in other words
if you found the exact same type of life
on uh on mars and
you know perseverance digs up a rock and
there's all of a sudden there's
a slime mold that i just you know washed
out uh from my coffee cup i don't know
if the world would act differently but
the question then
was asking is yeah are they staying away
because they see the first signatures
of advanced technology being you know
radar being used to track nazi warplanes
in world war ii
and then immediately afterwards they see
this huge flash of gamma rays from the
detonation of atomic weapons
maybe they're staying away because they
look we're violent civilization
um that is the plot of uh one of the
famous most famous science fiction
movies
ever made that was it the day the earth
stood still you know i mean
it's possible i i tend to you know i'd
like to try and stay away from alien
sociology
right about how they would think i just
like i said i just can't even begin to
imagine
how um i have no i have no guard rails
you know i have no bumper rails for
thinking how an alien society are they
capitalist are they communist are they
you know
um i just don't there's nothing that
science gives me that can help me sort
of
you know say like well that's
unreasonable or that's reasonable
whereas like you know for physics
chemistry and even some basic biology i
feel like you know i've got some things
so it's possible but again i will also
you know now let's enter science because
what i feel like is anytime we do that
we're just telling science fiction
stories which is cool
but um uh but you know i would imagine
that any civilization that could
travel between the stars like would not
really worry very much about our
puny weapons um so you know that's
you know they would be so advanced that
they would be like you know to our
little nuclear weapon so if you have
time for a couple more questions adam uh
there are some good ones in here so
there's one on the stellar astrophysics
front in your wave model in the wave
model
uh do you account for feedback
supernovae
star formation rate of its own uh
planetary nucleation agglomeration do
you account for how much astrophysics is
going into that
versus you know predator not predator
prey but but expansion and differential
equations of the
typical um exponential growth curves
right well like i said that's an
agent-based model i mean this is one of
the interesting this is a whole thing we
could talk about the difference between
you know simulating via partial
differential equations and and
agent-based models
totally i mean it's fascinating to me
because i'm also interested in modeling
so you know societies and
civilizations themselves and this offers
a whole new tool um
but uh so what you know it's a real
galaxy model um it is we included
supernova we allowed it you know we
allowed regions to sort of sterilize
um and uh we didn't do things like star
formation rates or because we didn't see
really how that
that mattered as much but certainly like
you know gamma ray bursts can
sterilize regions of the of the galaxy
but what we found is it just didn't
matter like you'd sterilize the region
for a while and then
you know you'd be able to unless there's
no reason it's not gonna be sterilized
forever
right after a while you know you wipe
out all life in a uh you know a 300
parsec bubble
and then eventually you know that could
be refilled
and i was surprised because look i
wanted i was looking for a way
to stop that that wave stop the wave and
like and so
it's a great example of science where i
had to be like okay
i was wrong um and there was just no way
to stop the wave but we did find what
was cool was that the steady state
the steady state offered you ways out of
and that just again shows you how
beautiful science is and also
how smart jonathan carroll is my you
know my long time former graduate
student now long time collaborator
because he was the one who saw like wait
a minute it's not just the wave it's
what happens after the wave
you know propagates so there are ways
you can get there are param regions of
parameter space where that steady state
has big voids
um uh that that are not being colonized
as long as you have finite lifetime for
the civilization right
well adam we are getting an alien
message from a distant distant alien
intelligence
saying please subscribe to this channel
and exercise your right to vote with
your thumb and your finger and
you we are the only species we know that
has this external opposable thumbs
uh please read and buy adam's uh book
which i have loved
since uh before i even knew that we
would be co-authors in the same
stable um and hopefully have a new book
coming out uh you're talking about maybe
this fall or later and then maybe even
an
after book some of which you may have uh
shown my my listeners in an early expose
so i really appreciate you adam i love
this book
you can still enter the competition
folks out there you can still enter the
competition to win
a copy of it unfortunately i can't send
it out of the united states ucsd
postal regulations uh will shut me down
that crusty old dean
no no my dean is great i love my dean
but i want to thank you on behalf of
eric very the director of the artsy
clark center for human imagination
here at the university of california san
diego patrick coleman stuart volkow and
all of us here at the uh clark center
and i also want to uh thank you on
behalf of all my listeners on
brian keating youtube channel we'll put
this on the clark center youtube channel
but please we're trying to grow the
audience so share it with your friends
this afternoon today
uh which is wednesday uh june 16th 2021
we're gonna have at five o'clock pacific
time
a lively cordial debate between eric
weinstein
and michael shermer kind of taking pro
and con views of these
alien unidentified phenomena
whether it's adversarial military with
domestic
et cetera or if it's actual technology
or if it's just confirmation bias
and it's just something that we want to
see i'm kind of being the neutral
moderator and that will probably be
my last bit of alien content for some
time i
i have to move on to other other topics
but we do have an amazing audience and
that is coming later on today so make
sure you hit the notification bell
subscribe and leave a like and a comment
adam thank you so much it's such a joy
to meet you i hope to meet you in person
and i'm going to try to get you out here
one year for comic-con this year i think
it's
it's uh it's virtual but we're going to
have the comic-con museum here in balboa
park san diego and i want to watch you
to be there
excellent thank you brian thank you my
friend it's great everybody have a
wonderful rest of your day